SingularityNET is a blockchain-based platform
for artificial intelligence and it originated
really when I realized that two goals that
I had could be fulfilled simultaneously by
the same software platform.
One goal being providing a tremendous variety
of AI services created by a huge variety of
different developers across all areas in a
way that's decentralized and democratically
controlled rather than within the proprietary
silos of big tech companies; and the other
goal is to work toward powerful and beneficial
artificial general intelligence.
And what I realized at a certain point is
you can achieve both of these goals by making
a framework where multiple AIs written by
multiple people can be put into a common platform
where they can not only serve requests from
end users but they can exchange data among
each other and the different AIs in the network
can ask questions of each other and help each
other solve problems.
So you have multiple AIs in the same network
that, you know, they can compete with each
other for providing services, but they also
cooperate and link together into networks
of cooperation.
So the whole network of AIs becomes this sort
of meta-AI, a society and economy of minds,
which is in itself a kind of emergent-level
mind.
So there's a commercial aspect of low cost
AI services across vertical markets providing
incentive for any AI developer to contribute
into the network, and there's sort of a broader
singularity-aterian motive, which is 'Hey
what's the best way to create the framework
within which artificial general intelligence
can crystallize and emerge?'
The role of blockchain in SingularityNET is
really to enable secure decentralized control.
So without blockchain, of course we could
make a distributed network of AIs that all
talk to each other and share data and outsource
work to each other, but we need to have like
some central control point that kept a record
of who's in the network, who's allowed to
enter into the network and what each guy in
the network can offer to whom.
And then if there was going to be a change
to how it operated all the changes would propagate
from the central control point.
What blockchain lets you do is have a network
of AIs all cooperating and operating by a
common protocol but have no central controlling
and governing agent.
Rather the records of what happens in the
network are stored distributive – we have
copies of the records everywhere.
And then control is governed by democratic
decision making among all the participants
so it's like a digital biological organism
with no central point of control, and this
has various advantages in terms of the inter-operation
of this network of AIs with the human world
and with countries and companies and people
because it means there's no one person or
company or government who owns the thing or
controls the thing.
And this puts the network in a quite different
status relative to the world economy and human
society than if there was a single human owner
who is responsible for everything.